[Music]
all right everybody here we are in a
most remarkable place we're at the
headquarters New York City of Jacob and
Co now we've got Mr Jacob himself here
this guy's a legend in the watch
business why because he did a transition
a morph if you want to call it that from
being a jeweler classic Jeweler very
successful Jeweler into one of the
world's Premier watchmakers but not just
any watch
I call these pieces absolutely insane
these are off the charts these are crazy
unbelievable movements I mean it's
Legend and I've brought Teddy with me
because he is my grasshopper and I have
to show him new ideas all the time and
bring him into the watch World in a big
way
Jacob meet Teddy hello Teddy Jacob
pleasure to meet you yeah good to see
you too sir so the reason we're wearing
these gloves is these timepieces are
incredibly rare incredibly expensive and
we're going to take you on a journey for
collectors when you found all you want
to buy of Rolex and all the protects you
need and all the aps you've got and you
have every Zorn
that's when you hit Jacob because you
there's nothing like this on the planet
so let's start the journey together why
don't you walk us through your move into
Jacob and I want to say something I have
two on my wrist this one is the first
watch she ever made my favorite of all
of his watches his entry level watch is
a painting outside the office with this
on it everywhere I wear this people say
what the hell is that really tell us
about this yes so this is called five
time zones it's five times on watch is
the very first watch I designed uh when
I drew this watch on the piece of paper
people throw them funny this is Mickey
Mouse watch but I said no we love I love
the colors I love this uh beautiful
colors because I could wear I would
Supply four bands for the watch nobody
did that before Red Band for me of
course red you had yellow blue you know
whatever colors was in the face you had
those colors in the Box what was in your
head designing that dial
oh that's fun watch to have something
fun and tell you five time zones because
at the time 2001 a lot of uh people were
moving around the world for you know
whether they're doing shows or TV shows
or musicians or Sports people so they
want to know what time is it in Japan
yeah Tokyo what time is it in L.A what
time is it in New York I actually these
are big enough to actually see the time
and it's one of my most precious watches
in the sense that I actually use it for
that reason when I travel plus it's a
lot of fun what do you think Teddy when
you first saw that how nuts is that it's
very unique it's very different Jacob
question for you so when you you had
this reputation as a jeweler what
allowed you to push forward was it your
own just personal pursuit or were you
also getting a lot of requests from your
clientele that you wanted to move into
watches how did that work well since I
become a jeweler
um I always wanted to make my own watch
I'll tell you why
uh when I was 13 years old my father
gave me a watch as a gift and I still
have it and it's really touched me you
know and it was so special this watch
was not that expensive it was dual time
zone
two mechanical movements simple with the
world that I could show with you I think
I have it here even like to show it to
you so I always wanted to become either
watchmaker or make my own watch right
and when the time came the right time
not that I had request or anything I
already had a successful jewelry
business I said now is the time for me
to design my first watch
and it was not easy it's very
challengable to go to Switzerland to to
have to convince someone to actually
make your watch you know it wasn't easy
and here it is yeah yeah that's why it's
legendary for me to be the beginning of
a trend of a movement of a Big Brand
that's developed this way but let's get
into where you went because these pieces
particularly some of the ones we're
going to see are are just they're almost
imaginary watches yes to get designers
to make these things it's just pushing
the status quo what is possible for
watchmaking a lot of ways unconventional
going against the norm in every yeah so
let's start with something that you're
really proud of I am very proud of
everything in this box a little bit of
okay pull some out of each let's get to
the hardware here uh we can start from
very first complication that I did you
know I always wanted to make something
never been made before you know I I
always saw this guy where did you get
this idea of giant size I mean these are
Big statement pieces well some of them
are big and some of them are smaller but
um to me because I always look at on my
wrist and I have a big wrist and I kind
of make a watch for myself first and you
see who follows yeah and then I see
maybe there's a few more people would
like it you know so this is first very
first in the world made 31 day power
Reserve 31 days so all the month all of
those are Barrel Stacks so you have how
many barrels are stacked specifically on
top I think there's a seven but you have
here 31 day calendar wow and this is the
time zone I mean I've never seen a
movement like that and it's most
important yeah yeah it's like that just
feel the weight of that that's in white
gold this also comes in titanium that's
very light white gold wine through these
little flaps on the side and then you
also have now again no one ever did
vertical turbine this was very first
vertical turbine it's pretty cool right
I mean that's that's just I mean that's
that's right off the charts I mean
nobody was thinking that way when you
brought this to the market this was
success and what do critics say when
they showed up with something like this
like wow what's that looks like an
engine of the car what is it and the
idea came from very simple uh places
like you see this um
barrels when I was a kid we had this uh
Electrical uh meter meter uh you know
yeah that's where I got the idea it was
identical as this so I took the idea and
put it in here I mean that's that piece
is absolutely stunning and at the time
when I made the 31 day power reserve the
the most power Reserve was 14 days by
IWC well you have enough room in that
thing it's a tank it's a tank it's a
tank all right something else different
direction right so next after that I um
I will introduce you
to let's see the next important piece I
designed was astronomia
astronomia this is legendary too you've
heard about this when I think of Jacob
Co I think of the astronomia first yes
this is this is really what puts you on
the map yes I mean it's just it's 3D
yeah this is the one where people said
who is this guy what is he doing what
the hell is that what's going on here I
took a big chance no kidding because
when you develop things like this it may
not work
you know it physically may not work yeah
because you could plan it you could
develop it and you could build it for
three years and then in the end it's
just not workable so I took a chance and
we developed this whole system where you
have you know the whole movement
actually rotating this became your
signature look when I see this piece on
people's hands all around the world I
know exactly what I'm looking at nobody
else makes pieces not this the teddy
look at this this is incredible you know
I I wanted to look to make it perfectly
rounded and it's incredible that's crazy
I mean this slowly this is a breakout
watch in my view because it kind of made
you who you are in the watch space and
then you started doing you know some
differentiation from that including this
latest thing we're looking at in a
minute but that is I think incredible
shortly after this I designed this watch
where it's much more complicated than
astronomia it's a sky astronomia
has three more functions and three more
complications it has
[Music]
it's just I made it a little bit smaller
if you see it has the DNA of this piece
yeah of course yeah it's got this
running seconds as one of the arms right
running seconds you have the globe on
top that's showing you night and day
it's 24 hours then you have the whole
movement again moving all the way around
for in 10 minutes Revolution you have
the Moon that does 60 seconds as well
and you have the uh turbine case that's
also 60 seconds I'm on the outside
that's the most important part in the
sky is a sea drill calendar that's usual
calendar accurately showing you stars
above yourself so the sigil dial the
bottom blue plate with the Stars it
takes one year for full full rotation
yes exactly one year that's how slow it
goes
so that's the complication of this watch
and no matter how much this rotates the
time is over showing correctly the
dialogue let me watch like this do you
go to the designer and say Here's what
I'm envisioning you design it you put I
design it and my engineers make it then
try to make it work yeah
you know there are times that my ideas
cannot be working I just say okay that's
enough I mean yeah we'll spend six
months we'll spend a lot of money on
this do you want to continue and then I
push and push I push and then the fence
all right next next interesting piece
after this we designed um
Twitter referees there's a watch behind
you actually yeah I love this watch
because again never been made before
um the reason I'm showing you uh with
diamonds because I don't have any other
ones in stock right now
um this watch has 920 components let's
talk about price on this one Jacob what
what does this cost doing the diamonds
is 1.3 million 1.3 million that's what
we're talking about here that's what
we're talking about I mean anybody
that's going to spend 1.3 million loves
the piece is a major collector
understands the vision of this piece and
obviously this is a showcase monster I
mean you're walking in with a piano on
your wrist here 920 components yeah two
two triple X turbines power Reserve from
the bottom power Reserve minute repeated
repeat it morning chronograph
pit board
you can go on and I don't know
it's so complicated on the slide do it
come on pull it push it
now for your protection it takes time
look at that you hear me
there it is
beautiful
yeah
you have to
fantastic yeah it's singing a song
that's a fantastic and that's only 2 30
now if you put it like quarter to 12
you'll get a lot more yeah that's crazy
and monopusher chronograph you want to
Pusher Chrono take a look of the back of
the finishes of the movement please it's
a piece of art this is most difficult to
do
to finish every uh
Bridge bring another one yes sir so the
link goes on yeah the next proud piece
we could show you would be shown
is partnership with Bugatti as you know
yeah
this is the famous Bugatti piece yeah
this is a secret cylinder yeah this is
crazy because the way I designed this is
I wanted to put the engine inside
so what Crown operates the Pistons is it
right this is like a start button just
press it once and you'll see it works
yeah it's crazy so it actually combines
this is another kind of you know I saw
this first in Dubai I think and watch
week I think the first time everybody's
talking about this I mean this is a a
branded relationship with Bugatti yes
it's branded relationship they're very
pleased with what we're doing I mean and
um
crazy no and from an engineering
perspective this is remarkable no
question about it thank you that's
another kind of Jacob you know pillar
this this piece it was a that was really
well received it was it crazy yes and
like I said I only make things that I
love myself so look at that and this is
a Sapphire version yes this is our proud
Sapphire rare version it was so
difficult to make because as you can see
it's one solid piece that's incredible
most of the sapphire crystal watches are
made by sandwich
uh like several layers much easier to do
this is what's most difficult I even
regretted that I did because it was very
difficult the price on these
it's one solid piece uh the Gold version
goes to a 380 000 380 000 and the
sapphire 1.3 million wow yeah 1.3
million yeah Teddy if price was not an
object what would you take of these two
probably go with uh gold the gold looks
beautiful yeah gold it reminds me of the
car itself no yeah never Dynamic Line
This I mean just seeing how that
emulates like the Pistons on an engine
I'm not even a car guy and this is this
is fascinating to watch actually yeah
this is this is uh yeah the collection
will be sold out very soon but I think
it first uh two quarters uh in 2023 it
will be all delivered and then we're
gonna start a new project
so when people
relationship with a customer
do they come with uh
customers are more like hey this is what
we're producing you have standard
production pieces but I imagine there's
a lot of projects that you walk hand in
hand with a customer on too it's really
really that it works with the customer
and consumer I'm mainly design
manufacturer and deal with distribution
but some of them people that I know
close enough to me that I do business
with yes let's see another one so the
next big piece this is interesting then
we decided to do something out of the
ordinary very understanding
I mean that is just
you know like in 2016 I think of 17 I I
was kind of bored and I said you know
I'm going to Boston show I don't feel
like I have enough to show so I told my
team we're gonna build a watch that's
gonna be called a billionaire so what is
a billionaire yeah the billionaire so
this is billionaire the name is
billionaire so the first watch I mean
built I built it for the show it was 18
million dollar watch what is is that the
price of this no this is three million
so imagine the 18 it had large diamonds
same with the watch was the same size
more or less just much larger diamonds
so instead of one block of diamonds here
the several was one big one so big
Stones although that's what made the
price yeah so we made this watch and it
made so much noise so much publicity in
the Basel show of course my whole team
thought I'm crazy making that watch but
then in the end they realized it was
worth it it did it sell of course
somebody has it yeah foreign
[Music]
how many diamonds are we talking here in
the setting here this one is has 170
carats it's not just diamonds you know
it's not so easy to just put together
every stone has to be cut specially to
fit in this this is blending your
history as a jeweler extraordinaire with
the watchmaker extraordinary coming up
with something just I mean it's
what can you say about this there's no
description so you have like a bigger
than life yeah see is it a white gold
backing to this that sets all the stones
is that how that works this is etch each
part yeah
yeah each link is connected of course
yeah yeah the stones are set on them and
you almost have to design it for the
wrist that it's going on because yeah
I mean I mean that that really is I hope
the camera will be able to photograph
this without burning the lens off it's
like looking into the sun yeah it was
just that's right that's everyone who
buys it you know this is a limited
edition of 18 pieces of that yeah
everyone who's buying a bottle it's
super happy with it yeah all right keep
going that's just right it's not for
everyone no no definitely not I mean
then
um uh then we have epic X this is
simpler watch this is more for someone
who doesn't want to spend a lot of money
it's a simple
um balance wheel
um
skeleton watch with rose gold or
titanium usually comes nice yeah nice
colors what's the case the size on this
this is It's a 44 millimeter okay yeah
again more toward the traditional Motif
you know the design
shows you can go in both directions yep
and then of course we wanted to have our
regular chronograph watch this is a 47
millimeter I recognize that yeah that's
the one you're wearing it exactly very
products in different colors nice
hmm so there's even moving more towards
the classic Sports piece yeah right okay
let's keep going yeah then uh we missed
one more we made uh you know when we
made this uh what I made the um
astronomium then women want the
Gastronomy but then I made a solar
astronomia yeah that's actually that is
very Tutti Fruity yeah it's Tutti Frutti
but the reason is because you have every
planet in there including the sun
solar system I do the whole solar system
and fit it in that watch that's very
approachable what's what's the size of
this case 43 43 yeah and the price on
this piece 348
000. yeah I mean it's the AR coating on
that is also you can if you look at it
it's very um doesn't look like you can
just grab that right now right you have
the globe that's rotating you have the
whole bottom to rotating and you have
it's really nice tourbillon cage this
has to be very popular because it's
approachable this is very very powerful
because men and women wear it yeah is
your astronomia your best-selling line
is that what most people associate with
your brand uh yeah I would say
everything sells equally but uh actually
normally though is your blowout yeah
that's what happened I mean when you
brought that piece people went who is
this guy even one astronomy was sent to
space really yeah yeah we there was a
very first Charter to space
four men flew to space for 17 days each
paid 55 million dollars to to fly and
one of them carried my astronomy watch
we have the videos in space how it's
floating in the air it's working
everything was working 100 and when it
came back we auctioned it for a charity
nice yeah how many watches been to space
all right before now there's one more in
there right uh this is actually similar
to what you're wearing I wasn't sure you
would be wearing yours
a regional I want to start with that but
I'm featuring the red band version of
this but it's it's a different color you
know the fact that it kind of started
you in this business is why I love it so
much and it's a great conversation I was
this was really uh that's very
functional frankly first of all it comes
also with diamonds and it was really
um successful how many years ago was
this jacob 2001 2001. 21 years 21 years
okay now let's bring out the Big Daddy
last one let's talk about this piece
this is the Godfather
you know I always loved that movie uh
I'm sure you've seen it right everyone
is it an Italian American of course did
you see the latest one the making of The
Godfather no I haven't well you should
it's called the offer
check it out I don't know if you did but
I haven't seen it yet please do because
that shows you how they made the first
three and what is the inspiration then
you love the movie how did you decide to
design this piece what were you going to
put in it and how did you get the rights
of this iconic brand exactly so I was in
Florence
but I always wanted to do something with
Hollywood you know I wanted to be you
know to do something in Partnership or
invest in a movie or become an actor or
do something
so I was in this cathedral in Florence
and I walk here
and I hear The Godfather music playing I
said what here
in a cathedral
making the watch
I'm gonna make the idea inspiration
right there I will manufacture and
design Godfather watch
with the music with the music let's talk
about how many pieces you're making what
there's I contacted
Paramount Pictures yeah they uh but they
knew they knew you by then your your
reputation preceded you with these
pieces yes yes and so you were able to
negotiate the rights yeah and then
negotiated right and how many are you
making so we have regular Godfather
without this is 50-year anniversary 50
year anniversary is because 50-year
anniversary of Godfather we made 50
pieces
it's price price 550 000. 500 550 000
sold out yeah they are sold out yeah
then we have uh ongoing uh collection 88
pieces in rose gold and 88 in Black
titanium and that is still you'll be
making these for a few years it'll take
two three years to finish the meal oh I
can only make
uh four movements per month so to
satisfy this whole collection it takes
time
so you have triple axis tourbillon 630
components and then could you play the
chime for us sure
so you'll have 600 yeah triple extra
Beyond this is
why Lynn this is how you wind The Watch
it's rewind it yeah music books
right so let me put this back
you press this button
through here the theme hold it up here
I mean it just bring Memories Back for
the first movie
[Music]
so the rights to the music too yes of
course you're playing everything rotates
and the whole thing rotates and still
tells you what time it is amazing it's
really something it's so complicated I
mean okay Teddy which is your favorite
piece
doesn't matter on price yeah let me face
it your way so what are you gonna do I
need like this at least you know this is
this is a style that I I mean I'm kind
of boring you know I'm more traditional
but
either this
or the Bugatti yeah just because I would
agree with you the Bugatti is so unique
spectacular and and just eye candy to
watch the Pistons are crazy it's insane
but this is also really something else
you it's it's so three-dimensional
yeah you see you see the crystal on the
bottom it's one ring it's also never
been made before it's one whole sapphire
crystal ring I mean that is so Jacob
for a couple of years more complicated
the better for me inspired by impossible
that's fine do you agree with my paper
what do you think I actually I I would
really suffer between these two because
I I love
I love I love the Pistons
that's just we'll get some close-ups of
this but yeah there's nothing else like
that in order it's crazy but this is
also really spectacular I like watches
that my wife would want to wear I mean
just so that you can share it together
yeah I mean that's like she's pretty
compact look at that I mean it's
basically just one Circle 43 millimeters
it's not that orange
all right and by the way the way those
stones are cut we invented that this is
288 facets on each Stone it's called
Jacob cut so it's our own pattern it's
incredible where are the where where are
the artists that do that where they look
Stones cutting yeah some in Thailand
color stones in Thailand and then
diamonds are in Israel
it's amazing this is only a couple of
people know how to do it Jacob it's been
an amazing journey thank you for your
time Teddy what have you learned today
this is a brand that I mean seeing some
of these for the first time in person so
this is I mean from an engineering
perspective
even if the style is not for you you
have to absolutely give kudos to what's
going on here I mean it's so over the
top
it's just but it pushes boundaries and I
think partially if hey that's what watch
Mickey's all about yeah
it's fantastic thank you so much my
pleasure and great thank you very much
for making time thank you I'm here great
to meet you that is great
thank you all right everybody what a
journey I want to watch I mean this is
why we do this so that you can
experience these incredible moments from
the Bugatti to this
I was just too crazy yeah that's what it
is it's just too crazy thank you
welcome
again
until next time till next time